The joe rogan experience.
Oh you know,
they've,
they've done some really interesting studies work cause you know,
they just over the last 10 or 15 years ago,
we see inside the brain,
I for the first time ever,
they again these Fmr I and where do you see inside the brain?
And they found people who've been identified as say this and they show them
pictures of people being hurt intentionally and they're like happy joy centers
light up their little like bring dancers.
That's all messed up.
You know,
cause it's like opposite planet,
you know,
all things.
We've got this thing from religion,
like everyone has a soul and we're all kind of equal,
all made in the image of God and this and that and the other.
But it's according to this,
people I've talked to in the research that I've done,
I mean there's some real predators among us who really are not kind of like us
at all.
And it's somebody who likes cs,
you know,
some being driven over and he giggles and finds that really quite thrilling.
I mean that,
I don't even know what species they have it.
And I think they're alive and you're going out there that they make like kind of
difficult for the rest of us.
It's a real issue.
It's very scary.
And how are these people becoming that?
Is it because of nature or nurture?
Is it because of,
you know,
abusive,
they've personally suffered and that sort of stimulating?
Yeah.
Well,
so I mean this is the fascinating thing about epigenetics,
right?
So I mean,
when I was a kid growing up,
but there was this nature versus nurture.
Like you got your genes,
that's what you're born with,
right?
And then maybe you can influence it a bit with nature.
But what they're finding out now is that genes turn on and off depending on
experience.
So they found like if you have a particular gene and you're a boy and you are
physically abused as a child,
almost for certain,
that you're going to end up,
you know,
on the bad side of things,
like you're gonna end up violent,
aggressive criminal j or whatever.
Right?
Now,
if you don't have that gene,
you're abused,
you've likely heard,
but it's less.
Uh,
and so certain genes for aggression get turned down and strengthened based upon
your experiences.
You can end up deck twins who grew up in different households can end up with
different genetics based on their environment.
So that's what so important about,
you know,
something I focus a lot on is the parenting,
parenting parents.
It seems to be so many people are out there and they're just so messed up.
Like you just,
you can't rewind and you can't send them down a different path.
But if you kind of look at the next generation,
the next generation,
what if we could have the percentage of people spanking their children down from
90%.
I mean,
it seems so weird and the 21st century that that's how parents are really
focused,
depending on where you counted.
80 to 90%.
It's less so in Europe,
like in Sweden,
I think it's been banned since like 1973.
And y'all know what a hell hole Sweden is.
They're doing fine.
But um,
yeah,
it's still 80 to 90% in,
uh,
well it's legal here.
It's legal in America from two to 12.
You can hit a child in Canada illegally,
just not of the face and not with an implement.
Um,
so,
oh,
I care about is the opponent in front of me and uh,
and that fight,
I don't,
I don't do anything to,
to go out there and lose man,
fuck that.
And I go out there to go to war and,
and be the nastiest Munis individual I can be.
And I view the fight as the most important thing and everything else is,
if I was thinking about the things surrounding the fight and in and separating
that from the flight was more,
that would be more difficult for me to navigate because that's also not
necessarily all within my control,
but the full kind of thing specifically,
oh,
you know,
you've got your media days and this and what you should say,
what you're trying to do and maybe getting this sponsor all these different
little things that have,
that are not,
that are not directly a controllable by you or she can get in the way.
Right.
Oh,
of course it can,
but I separate the two.
I keep them completely,
entirely separate.
And at the end of the day I will throw away everything that is not the fight.
The fight is what gets you what you want.
You know,
I always say over and over again,
if you,
if there is nobody left alive to stop you from taking what you want,
then you,
you can have all the trophies and trinkets and all that stuff.
Then everything is left.
It's the spoils of war.
So go out and win your war and then deal with the rest later.
There's an article about it online.
It says,
Janice,
Stan's male soldiers are having sex with other guys,
but don't call them homos.
Well there was also something where like,
ah,
they were like their soldiers.
They would have a young boy who would have to service everybody,
check this and they had to tell the soldiers,
don't get upset about that.
But yeah,
don't get involved.
That's their custom.
Whoa.
Well we know their customers that the young girl that died,
she was sold away way to marriage.
She was eight years old.
She died after having sex with a guy.
Let's listen to this Afghanistan's will the,
the article is in a query,
um,
free of an agenda except that gay one,
queerty.com queer like instead of Cordy Queerty how Ha Alex every day when they
got that domain
as I love,
I love the title to a free of agenda.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Um,
and it's talking about a,
it says Afghanistan's mail.
Sir soldiers have a sex,
have sex with other guys,
but don't call them homos.
And it says,
it's really interesting.
It says America's gay soldiers have unique struggle in their hands,
whether the hide or be open about their sexuality.
But Afghanistan's gay soldiers have a different battle despite regularly having
sex with other men and shunning women.
Many of these male soldiers refused to identify as gay,
which can get in the way of say,
preventing STDs.
You need only watched the CNN clip below where three gay American troops speak
of the need to repeal,
don't ask,
don't tell,
which has been repealed.
Now I believe to understand the difficulties of being gay in the US armed forces
here.
The oldest article is from man love.
Thursdays has its own post on urban dictionary.
It's a the article,
it doesn't say where it's from here.
Unfortunately it doesn't say what year.
So it was before.
Don't ask,
don't tell was repelled.
So I don't,
hmm.
Repealed rather.
Um,
for these Afghan soldiers.
However,
having sex regularly with other men is no big deal.
Just don't call them gay and unclassified study from military research unit in
southern Afghanistan.
That's a funny statement.
An unclassified study from a military research unit in southern Afghanistan
that's looking into gay sex details,
how homosexual behavior is unusually common amongst men,
among men in the large ethnic group known as Pash Dunes,
PA ash t you ends Pashtuns,
although they seem to be in complete denial about it.
What's a new unclassified study of past June meant,
oh,
that's,
that's what the new,
uh,
unclassified study revealed these men admire.
Other men physically have sexual relationships with boys and shun women both
socially and sexually.
Yet they completely reject the label of homosexual.
The research was conducted as part of a longstanding effort to better understand
Afghan culture and improve western interaction with the local people.
When you reach it like that and you read that,
you're like,
people are dying over there.
You know,
and you,
you think like the idea that they're going to try to change this.
You think about what they do,
where they marry off.
Eight year old girls cut women's noses off.
They do this kind of shit.
Pretend they're not gay,
whether fucking each other and be homophobic at the same time.
It's absolute madness.
It's reality your way right away.
It's like custom made reality.
This is what they do.
This is how they figured out their way around it.
The pash Dune men interpret the Islamic prohibition on homosexuality to mean
they cannot love another man,
but it doesn't mean they can't use men for sexual gratification.
What an interesting little gray area there.
There's a little fine print right there.
You're a fucking human being.